[Applause]
mr. Joe it's now
we are back thank you it has been a very
long eight weeks but I finally finished
the Irishman so long boy
dinero looks great i aged 40 years
that's what yeah we've been on vacation
but two months and I tell you when I'm
on vacation you know I have to I have to
recharge the batteries in my vape and
i-i-i don't follow the news but of
course no I'm back to work I was
following Trump all week and I just got
to say I need a vacation but we have we
have an amazing show to come back with
our Booker's outdid themselves Nancy
Pelosi is here tonight
and Andrew yang is there tonight and of
course his supporters his supporters are
called the yang gang and Bernie
supporters are called the Bernie Bros
and Trump supporters are called Russians
Russians in the news did you see this
week that return previously on real time
I feel like you do one of those
remember this character lived porn ass
from last season yo yeah looks like the
uber driver who says to you you want
girl Wow did he come out of hiding in a
big way he's on every show he started
with Rachel Maddow she did a great job
interviewing him everything everything
apparently everything he says he told
that he and Giuliani were doing in
Ukraine came at the direct direct
direction of President Trump and of
course Republicans are saying that
Parnassus is making something out of
nothing I say cheap shot leave his air
out of this
Trump of course denies even knowing him
he always does this
someday I promise you Don jr. is gonna
get indicted and Trump will say I knew
him very briefly because my son for a
short period of time I had my picture
taken with a lot of people but this
impeachment trial is happening the
Republicans of course all Republican
jerks are desperately trying to keep any
witnesses from testifying as you do when
you're completely innocent
Mitch McConnell says we will leave no
stone turned we always gotta get
acquitted I mean trial please we
shouldn't even use the word it's a few
minutes of wrote formularies followed by
Trump getting off or or or as Melania
calls it sex
and this was the most amazing being
today Trump announced some of the people
on his dream team of lawyers did you see
this Ken Starr yes that Ken Starr the
guy for whom the blow job was too much
he's defending this mist impeachment guy
and also Alan Dershowitz who has
defended Weinstein OJ and now Trump Wow
think about that Trump Weinstein and OJ
flabby grabby and stabby
but the the trial will begin on on
Tuesday and you know this is in the
Senate where they take their decorum
right the Senate very seriously not
those animals in the house and oh yeah
we have decorum so there's gonna be no
phones no talking so expect a lot of
tension a lot of angry glares a lot of
dirty looks and that's just between
Elizabeth Warren and just did you see
the debate that got nasty the democratic
debate as you know Elizabeth Warren a
couple of weeks ago played the woman
card and said Bernie and a private
meeting a couple of years ago said a
woman can't get elected president and
then at the debate Bernie was asked
about this and he said no I didn't and
he said and besides that the fact that
you would say that is just like a woman
so after the debate Elizabeth Warren
went right up to him you saw this moment
and he went to shake her hand and he
said don't touch me have you haven't
seen the movie marriage story this is
like that movie in seven seconds she's
like you called me a liar and he's like
why are you bringing up old [ __ ] let's
not do this here no I want to talk about
in front of the whole restaurant so
maybe the most important thing that
happened was a new book came out by two
reporters in the Washington Post
where Trump called America's top
generals the military people who we
always say you know we thank you for
your service said they were dopes and
baby said this right to their face this
isn't a meeting a couple of years ago
and he said I wouldn't go to war with
you and they were like yeah we know we
were in Vietnam
I'm ending with that to remind you this
is it this is the year
this is 2020 this is where it's gonna
have to happen where we desperately need
to get rid of this bed he needs to be
removed there's only three ways he goes
impeachment election or fried chicken
and I don't have faith in the first of
the third so we are going to have to
make that happen okay
you